good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Wednesday hope
everyone's having an amazing hump day
thus far humping someone they love
getting real down and dirty speaking of
dirty how's my favorite girl hey Jax how
you doing you could have rhymed that
really nicely speaking of nerdy how's my
favorite girly
[ __ ] should we restart no no it's okay
we know for next time I'm doing great
because I'm spending a hump day with the
woman I love the clergio laterio
that is me in case you were wondering it
is you and I'm just so grateful to be
spending another day of saving the bees
it was another great day let's talk
about that let's talk about how it was
another great day of saving the bees
yeah I'm happy to talk about that
because it is and honestly bees are so
important for our ecosystem
would say integral integral do we have
an ad for beekeepers natural today we
don't because that would have been a
wonderful segue but we do have deer
toasters it's Wednesday we haven't been
we haven't done deer toasters in a while
like the people are needing our hair
they're not okay they're not okay we've
got baby names Steelers a Shayla
situation on our hands which is always
tough yeah ooh can't wait to hear I hope
they give us the name too to see if it's
worth fighting over
okay they actually did give us the name
and I don't know you know a lot of times
when people write into Deer toasters
they use fake names because obviously
they don't want people in their life
maybe hearing the podcast so I don't
know if it's a fake name I hope it's not
I hope it's not because it it's all
dependent on what the name is
right like if it's mclario the turtle
you fight to the death for it
I agree that's a name worth dying for
100
um so it was so good to be back
yesterday let me tell you how I don't
often watch our own episodes back
because I just get very like
self-critical and the sound of my own
voice makes me want to die but I did
watch yesterday's episode because I felt
like we were really like on one and it
was so good to be back and that I felt
like a toaster what was your favorite
part
probably just every time I spoke if I'm
being honest so the whole episode
pretty much like when I take pictures of
people or record videos like me and Ben
will take a picture and I will literally
get to the stage of posting it before I
realize Ben's eyes are closed you know I
don't even look at another human being
unless it's me and that's just me being
honest I understand I feel like most
people are that way and I'm glad that
you love what you're bringing to the
table
um I just hope that doesn't Inspire like
more talking over me less Jackie talking
I don't know I'm so good I'm so good
like so am I watching but so every time
every time I was watching I was like oh
my God that girl that girl on the right
she's got charisma
she's got uniqueness she's got nerve
She's Got Talent she also has a
wonderful partner who who really like
alley oops it's a real alley-oop
situation it's a lob and a noop it's a
lab yeah
speaking of spurts let me tell you how I
thought our conversation about sports
yesterday was so interesting and we're
literally becoming sports influencers
like I had there must be a lot of social
media managers who work for different
teams because like the invites are
pouring in like come to Portland like
I'm really like I'm kind of like Charles
Barkley
yeah that's what I think too I think
you're Shaq that's where your career is
headed
I wouldn't mind it I think that there's
like so many jobs in the talk sports
radio realm like as talking girls if we
did and you know women are really
underrepresented in the sports like if
you did want to make Sports your
expertise except like it requires a
level of historical knowledge that's
like on par with Housewives except
actually even more because it's been
going on hundreds of years
um and there are more players if you did
want to make that your beat like I think
you would have ample job opportunities
I think so too like I I think Aaron
ehringer should sleep with one eye open
I think she does I think because she had
like a stalker situation by the way
that's so weird that you said that
because I was actually thinking about
that situation the other day when like
somebody drilled a hole in her hotel
room and put a camera and took pictures
of her naked
um I think because I was naked in my
hotel room in on vacation I was just
thinking how vulnerable I felt like
being in like a different and I just was
reminded of that Erin Andrews situation
and how [ __ ] crazy that was that is
crazy I didn't realize that's what had
happened exactly that there was yeah
and I believe she sued and won did she
Sue Marriott or she sued the stalker I
don't know
it was a crazy situation I just that's
weird that you brought that up because I
was literally thinking about her the
other day yeah so there's like a couple
other girlies out there doing it shout
out to the you know and I feel like
actually a lot of them are toasters
because sometimes I'll like click on a
verified toaster and they're like a news
you know sideline girly uh but I just
feel like you know if you ever want to
Pivot I support you I would pivot but
not to the sidelines because that sounds
like a lot of standing up one thing like
I love about my job is that I do it
sitting down and you do it most of the
time in a temperature controlled
environment right so I don't think
sideline reporting would be for me but I
would love to be like the halftime show
back at the studio maybe I could sing a
song during the halftime oh yeah and you
could like digest debrief talk about
what's been going on I feel like I feel
like these Sports shows need official
Wags correspondence because I feel like
when you can get to what's going on in
the wag world of a team you can really
understand the health of a team
so I think that's actually what e was
trying to do with the show Wags but then
they like randomly canceled it I think
because the term wag is considered
derogatory and they were trying to be
like a women's Network they're always by
the way I just I'm about to make the
world's best comparison okay
E news no not nutty the e-network
is the Miley Cyrus
of channels like every couple of years
like Reinventing themselves being like
no this is the real age yeah Miley's
doing that right now like she has this
huge campaign Billboards all over the
world like new year new Miley like new
Miley like we didn't know the real Miley
before got it and so she's go she's
going with a new image this year yes she
has a new image coming out I guess we'll
have to wait and see what it is I saw
some images from her New Year's Eve bash
and and the image I was seeing was her
being like pretty polished but still
like rock and roll you know she's
wearing yeah a classy gown like with her
tattoo and all that jazz right no in her
dyed hair it's like bleach blonde but
also black in the back
um I like the era of Miley we've been in
for a while The Rocker
[Music]
like I liked I liked that era but I
guess it's coming to a close like Miley
is constantly Reinventing herself to the
point where it's like kind of exhausting
not kind of like we are exhausted we've
been together for years too like I can't
be changed was supposed to be the real
Miley She Can't Be Tamed Miley Cyrus and
her dead pets oh my gosh finally I can
express myself bangers this is the real
Miley like for at Malibu is Malibu
stripped yeah no it's like every couple
of years it's like the real Miley's
coming out that's what he does like same
with Demi
is the queen of Reinventing herself via
documentary and Miley is the queen of
Reinventing herself via genre yeah
and E news is always like every couple
of years like we're gonna be a women's
Network and then every couple years
we're actually gonna be pop culture
we're gonna have we're perfect
pop then it's like actually we're going
to be family we're gonna do the Bradshaw
it's like they're always doing and then
there was like the Busy Phillips era
like they're always Reinventing
themselves
yeah they're always Reinventing
themselves and it never works I feel
like with Miley like actually a couple
of the times like it actually worked
like the Malibu era was very much it for
me I actually really like the rock era
she's been in right but when something
works like if it ain't broke don't fix
it like why can't we stay there no I
thought we were staying in the Rock era
like it took a few times for her to
actually really find herself and now she
had found herself in the Rock era Joan
Jett Vibes but it seems like there's a
new year new Miley we'll have to wait
and see but I feel like that's my least
statement on just like she's just being
mildly like she's always going to be
changing having new interests having new
Vibes and she even if she finds one that
suits her like nothing is static
so true it's constantly transforming
so true anyways uh I miss Wags on E but
no what I meant was like someone there
who's the wag correspondent like
that's their beat here's what's going on
with the wife's like here's who's like
hanging out here you know what color
like if we're going on double dates like
I'm probably gonna pass to you on the
field but if we were going on double
dates now we're not
I do think that the players very much
keep their social lives personal lives
and like this the field separate that's
why where the Wags come in because
they're showing everything and people
aren't paying attention
no there definitely needs to be like a
wax correspondent on SportsCenter I
completely I'm trying to get you a job a
lot there
yeah but I love my job
because pert time
hurt time I would love that
Yeah just something to think about
another thing to think about is how
beautiful we are I think that's
something we should definitely talk
about before we dive in we've got good
stories today it was so good to catch up
yesterday
um and then we're going to change some
lives into your toasters and this would
be a good time to remind you that you
know we are scraping the bottom of the
barrel I feel like I haven't promoted
you know submissions in a while so we're
almost at the bottom so we would love
some fresh submissions maybe something
you haven't heard yet here on the toast
reminder the email if you want to write
in every Wednesday we do an advice
segment where we're going to give you
the best unfiltered sometimes tough love
advice deertoesters gmail.com we will
never share your name you can change
little facts to keep it Anonymous but
it's important that
that you guys get involved in Deer
toasters because deer toasters is only
as good as the submissions yes and we
love deer toasters but I think you know
the hope the ultimate goal for your
toasters is that like
we solve everything and that one day
there are no more submissions because
like maybe maybe that's what's happening
is that like everybody's take we've done
so many over the years they're like
taking our advice from all of the
different ones and like they're just
applying it to their situation like
we've kind of just solved the world's
problems
no that's definitely an interesting way
of looking at it I I like where your
head is at because when you think about
kind of the energy we put forth into
your toasters but also just in the toast
itself I do really feel as though we're
making
people better
thus
decreasing their problems yeah bettering
people
right and this would also be a good time
if today's episode was sponsored by
betterhelp but it's not but also you
have to think about it and into your
toasters there's always you know like
the toaster who's being wrongfully
treated and then there's the villain and
maybe as the toast grows like those
villains are becoming toasters and
they're seeing themselves in these ear
toasters and listening to the show and
becoming better people so maybe there's
just like less villainous people out
there and that's why it's genuinely like
imperative that everyone listens to the
toast
genuinely
it's integral much like the bees
we are the bees we are the bees
we are the bees
are we the bees
I couldn't help but Wonder were we the
bees
I think we are
makes sense
um so we've got a great show I didn't do
much
um consummation consumption not content
I actually did do a little consummation
I didn't do any consumption yesterday so
I don't have any TV to recap I if you're
reading
I'm reading I'm reading some smut which
is always good A lot of people had
recommended uh
that's what they call like romance porn
novels why
no clue this is Hearts back to yesterday
I don't know but it's not like it
doesn't stamp or something like spicy
matronly he
you know underworldly Tales
[Laughter]
it might stand for something it might be
an acronym I don't know but smut is
books that are good but also have porn
so a lot of people had recommended a
good a book that like kind of went viral
over the seasons it was like a holiday
themed smut it was called tis the season
for revenge and it was really cute and
then I didn't know that it was actually
the second book in a sequel and as I was
reading it she was talking about her
sister and her husband and I was like
they sound like book one and I was right
it was book one so now I'm reading book
one I'm reading it um not in order but
it's fine these books don't really need
to be read in any specific order they're
not you know Harry Potter
no no no no no it's it's not um it's not
integral unlike the bees
understood so yes mud I guess would say
like if there's an app on the cover
yeah well so that's what's really
embarrassing is that recently
um someone in the literary space decided
to like take porn books and change the
covers making them like cartoons and so
if you're walking around with a book or
even your Kindle has the the book cover
on the front no one's going to know
you're reading porn because it's just
like a cute little cartoon it looks like
a cute romance novel but some of the
books are taking longer to update with
their old covers and
book two in this series has like a cute
little cartoon animation book one has
like a sexy man with his shirt off and
it's beyond embarrassing and I need I
need all the romance novelists to like
update their covers okay yeah but that
is just the Tale As Old As Time like I
feel like back it's very Real Steel yeah
women used to read romance novels and
it's like Lorenzo Lamas on the cover
Fabio and now you are going through the
same thing just like a new version of
and I feel like you know girls used to
like look at those books at the store
and be like who would read that and now
like that's what you're reading
essentially no for sure like you don't
watch Friends but at one point Joey is
looking for something in Rachel's Reuben
under her pillow he finds her novel and
it's like a Danielle Steel
um and they like mock her endlessly for
the episode about like this Chimney
Sweep who's sweeping the chimney
shirtless and that's literally what
those books are but they've just been
reinvented and I think whoever did that
is brilliant they've been reinvented as
smut but I don't know if it was
someone's like marketing decision or
just like women are women and when you
reach like a certain age in a stage in
your life and you're married and you
know the spiciness isn't always there I
say you bring it in yeah no it's so true
and now like it's it's considered like
cool now and it's like SMUD and spicy on
Tick Tock yeah but I think women have
been doing this even like when I read
some of my like Gilded Age books there's
like you know the one book they're all
passing around right no and I think and
actually another book I was reading like
a more serious book I can't remember
what I actually highlighted this passage
it's like we tend to mock things that
are really popular amongst women as like
childish or like weird and it got me
thinking like that's really what those
romance novels were for a long time and
I feel like Colleen Hoover and just like
the Advent of book talk like have really
um normalized and like taken the stigma
out of reading books like that like just
because it's a romance novel and it's
corny and there's like love scenes
doesn't make it any less compelling or
literary or important honestly yes and I
also think the Kindle has done that
because you don't have to walk around
holding Fabio on the cover you're
reading it looks intellectual but like
nobody needs to know what the [ __ ]
you're reading like no no unless you
want to share
no it's so [ __ ] true and like I chill
I I'm chilled at the thought of like you
know people who like to read these books
before Kindles and before the Rebrand to
cartoons like in the airport they were
probably like mortified yeah so then it
became like this you know shameful like
back door thing and that was just kind
of out in the open I think it's nice
I think it's nice I think Tick Tock was
huge for that honestly yeah
and the redheads obviously the redheads
obviously we're recording the new
episode today about the book of The It
Girl if you were ever thinking about
becoming a redhead one January is a
great month to do it new goals you know
we're starting the year as academics two
this book was so good it's a thriller
about an IT girl like said at Oxford
University it doesn't get more gorgeous
and I personally like had no idea
who done it what the twist yeah the
twist it was I thought it was so good I
want you to read it because you've been
really good on my list you've been
really good at predicting like you saw a
flicker in the dark coming from the
beginning which is crazy duh
duh
I did not so I want to see it and catch
this one I'm actually bad I feel like I
say this all the time like at movies and
books that have like murderous twists or
Thrillers I will never guess uh like I
even the most obvious things like movie
twists I'm like shocked by so with
reading I feel like I've gotten really
clever just because I've been reading so
much I'm like I know all these authors
tricks it's really hard for an author to
do something new so when they do it's
huge like Gone Girl
right so I am going to read the redheads
book before the not before the episode
before I listen to the episode because I
want to read it and I want to listen to
the episode it's a great time to become
a redhead it is so uh new episode drops
tomorrow and then next book is my choice
and I'm
I don't know I'm juggling a lot of
different choices do I go really serious
do I go with another Thriller because
that seems to be like what we can all
agree on is good and I I have a few
lined up that like I know are good they
have good ratings and they have good
reviews
um do I do a little more romance do I do
historical fiction I'm just not in the
mood no actually like being the person
who selects the book club book or even
being the person like
just it's the worst like you can't wait
for your turn and then it's your turn
and you're like oh I know it's it's so
much pressure
well while you're recording your
redheads I am going to such an important
doctor's visit that I can hardly contain
myself I haven't gotten Botox in well
over a year because yeah because I yeah
no you've had Botox since I've given
birth
maybe once yeah because I remember one
time like you were coming from there
um I don't think so but I haven't had in
a really long time and I consciously
stopped because while I was on tour and
I knew I was going to be filming a
special like I really I hate when my
face doesn't move when I'm doing comedy
it's like half of my comedy is just me
and my crazy face you know yeah so I had
to stop and now I'm so excited my
forehead is never gonna move ever again
and I cannot wait mine told it up like I
could go for some a refresh but it's
only been like three months so you don't
want to do it too often I feel like
that's the best part of getting Botox
it's not the immediate freezing it's
like when you start to regain a little
movement so you still look like you know
an expressive person but you don't have
crazy wrinkles I actually like that part
of the botox process a Manti movement
your anti-movement yeah
you're more of a conservative
why that would be anti-movement no like
you want to conserve like the forehead
yeah forehead I hate talking about the
word forehead yeah forehead
forehead
I know not on this show not on this show
and I don't know why we say the word
incorrectly
I don't know why either
and there's not like a group of people
who either pronounce it forehead or
forehead it's just everyone says
forehead
forehead no
forehead forehead
that's right now that that's settled I
think that we can get it and that we
should
we will at all get into the faster and
we shall
the past size story is that you need to
know
and today's past five stories that you
need to know are brought to you
by all birds when it comes to Quality
Mother Nature knows best and you could
take that idea and run with the wool
Runners from all birds trade your
synthetic Footwear this year for wool
Runners that are crafted from premium
Supernatural materials that are comfy
and durable so you can run to the ends
of the Earth or just to the store or
just to your kitchen wool Runners are
built using premium Supernatural
materials with low environmental
environmental impact so they're the next
level
um all birds they have Next Level
comfort with zq certified super fine
Merino wool that's temperature regulated
moisture wicking and itch-free nobody
that people are always talking about all
birds and like all the fabulous things
but nobody talks about their ability to
temperature control because like when
you're wearing sneakers your feet can
get so hot and like your shoe can become
literally an oven and that's why I
really like wearing all birds even
though I'm not like really physical but
I wear sneakers all the time like to the
toast shopping and I hate that feeling
of like your your foot becoming so hot
like a sauna almost and that's why I
really like the all birds they're
sugarcane-based sweet foam midsoles
contoured to your feet and put a little
bounce in your step they're machine
washable so they look as fresh as the
day you got them which is also one of
the best parts of all birds this year
take a big step forward for mother
nature with the all birds wool Runner
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com allbirds.com their
new wool Runners that are crafted with
premium Supernatural materials are
perfect for you today's episode is also
brought to you by Babel one of the most
exciting things about a new year is that
you have no idea what Adventures are in
store for you from new travel
experiences to new jobs or picking up
new skills there's no better way to
prepare for 2023 than by learning a new
language with Babel Babel is the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions and thanks
to Babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons you can feel
confident no matter where the New Year
takes you and thank God I had been
brushing up on my Spanish using Babble
because when I landed in Belize not
knowing like the most commonly spoken
language there is Spanish I felt so
prepared I felt so safe it's such a good
thing to do obviously learning a new
language is just a great way to expand
your mind a great hobby just like invest
in yourself but really if you do travel
a lot to link to countries with
different languages learning just the
basics on Babel is a really easy and be
really smart you never want to get stuck
somewhere where you don't even know like
right left bathroom things like that so
Babel's great if you're a traveler or if
you're just looking to expand your
horizons you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson and they offer over 14
languages like Spanish like German like
French like Italian so
um they're voiced their lessons are
voiced by real native speakers not
computers making it way more effective
and their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
toast that's babble.com toast for up to
55 off your subscription
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash toast Babble
language for life
thank you so much or shall I say gracias
de nada
I learned that on Babel
I'm not shocked okay our first story a
little new romance news Matthew Lawrence
from Boy Meets World confirms his
romance with TLC's chili three months
after divorcing from Cheryl Burke
it looks like Rosanda chili Thomas and
Matthew Lawrence are in Perfect Harmony
the TLC member and the Boy Meets World
Alum are in an exclusive relationship
and are very happy her rep confirmed to
e-news chilly and Matthew made their
relationship Instagram official on New
Year's Eve both sharing a video of
themselves dancing to aha's Take On Me
In matching PJs and captioning it
hashtag New Year Shenanigans hashtag
onesiegang weq the no scrub singers
reptile TMZ that the couple started
dating just before Thanksgiving and that
they spent the holiday as well as
Christmas together in Atlanta where he
met her family although chili and
Matthew have known each other for longer
as they were photographed soaking up the
sun in Hawaii in August
and it looks like fans are thrilled for
the pair quote my 90s heart is bursting
with joy for both of you
now the relationship two things going on
here the relationship news comes about
three months after by the way the Mrs
Doubtfire actor yes he is the son from
Mrs Doubtfire all grown up my God I did
never put that together that he's also
from Boy Meets World that he's the
second son I mean the second kid the
second kid and he's from
um the hot chick he's like the guy
you know hot chick isn't a movie that
stuck with me it's like it's from that
era of films that we loved and I feel
like my friends are always quoting it
and it's not a movie that I really ever
like gave a [ __ ] about yeah no but
anytime it's always on some random
Channel anytime I watch a piece of it
it's always really good
um anyways he was the the boyfriend love
interest he finalized his divorce from
Cheryl Burke three months ago the former
Dancing with the Stars profile for
divorce for Matthew on February 18th
after almost three years of marriage
citing irreconcilable differences as the
reason for their split and listing their
date of separation is January 7th
so there's a lot going on here the two
things going on are people are freaking
out that these two are dating because
it's very 90s it's iconic obviously TLC
Waterfalls iconic Boy Meets World Mrs
Doubtfire iconic and it's cute but
what's really more interesting about
this is the Cheryl Burke of it all from
Dancing With the Stars first of all I
know that Cheryl Burke like had recently
gotten divorced I was making tick tocks
about how she hates her's husband
because she had to pay for everything
literally like she was blowing him up on
Tick Tock and I never put together that
her ex-husband was this man like not
until literally this morning
literally who [ __ ] cares because you
would hear like what his name you would
just keep moving right and all of her
tick tocks were like how you paid for
everything and like you were the
breadwinner so I'm like oh obviously
he's a nobody like I literally like I
couldn't even be bothered to look at who
her ex-husband was but now it's more
interesting to me and Cheryl Burke since
this news has come out has like really
unloaded on Tick Tock and I have to say
I know she's the victim in this because
it appears as though like their
relationship timeline like is not Kosher
and he was definitely cheating on her
and she was saying in her Tick Tock that
he had numbers her number saved as his
brother and his phone like he was
definitely being nefarious and I know
that she's the hurt party here but like
she has to get off of tick tock because
it's making her look like a big loser
like her tick tocks are not like serving
in the way that she thinks that they're
serving like she's doing all of these
trends like thinking she's coming out on
top and she looks so sour she looks so
better and she looks like she doesn't
know how to use tick tock it's just so
weird to me if you like zoom out of the
situation that like
she went through a divorce from this man
they're now divorced and he's in a new
relationship and it also sucks to like
everyone's shipping his new relationship
and like her way of processing it is
taking to Tick-Tock and doing Trends
with the theme of her divorce like
that's [ __ ] weird if aliens came down
to earth they would be like what are you
doing
the first couple of times I saw the tick
tocks before I really knew the context I
just thought she was like to me she was
getting divorced from a man with no face
like I didn't know him I was like oh you
know what kind of love her throwing him
under the bus for like leaving her after
she literally like bankrolled their
lives like I I did I did like it but now
with all the context and like people
shipping and then her like just kind of
like clawing to like make an impact it's
really she has to stop she's making
herself look really bad especially
because people are shipping and the
timeline okay so that's where they were
together in Hawaii in August but they're
saying they started dating Thanksgiving
like let's say they started dating they
were dating in Hawaii and maybe they met
even a few months before like the date
of Separation was January 7th January so
okay he's going through a divorce but he
met someone else no we all know she's
saying that like
he was texting her I guess when they
were married right that's what she's
saying so they've been together well
over a year and it's been hush hush
I don't know yeah do you think they knew
each other like back from the 90s days
or like recently just connected
I don't know I don't know enough like
honestly I'm not a Boy Meets World girly
I don't know who they were hanging with
I don't know how big they were as stars
themselves especially if they weren't
like Corey and Topanga
yeah no they were both like
a part of something really big but not
like the biggest person in that in their
specific thing like he wasn't the
biggest star on Boy Meets World and she
wasn't the biggest star from TLC right
so I don't know how much their paths
might have crossed and like did TLC do
anything with the network That Boy Meets
World right no enough like it's not as
you know Nick and Jessica
right no for sure but it is like a
smaller version of that and like it is
cute and if it weren't for like the
Cheryl Burke at all I think everyone
would be shipping even more but I for me
the more interesting part of this whole
Saga like isn't the 90s reconnecting
it's Cheryl Burke's Tick Tock and I just
needed this to reach her like you are
not coming out looking like a winner you
have to stop the tick tocks like please
it's
it's
odd
it's odd and it's just it's giving I
don't know what the right word is but
it's giving like loser and I don't mean
loser as in like I mean as someone who
is losing yeah yeah and that's just like
how an 18 year old would behave if they
found out their boyfriend was cheating
on them yeah and like he also was a tick
tocker right
but this is just not it's not the place
it's not adult Behavior
it's not until Behavior it's not the
place you have to think about what the
aliens would think if they came down and
saw this they would be ashamed sometimes
that's the only way to get perspective
on something
so true like what would someone who has
no prior interest or knowledge of this
think about what you're doing
no it's amazing it's so true
well I think it's cute news I hope
Cheryl Byrd finds love she's on Dancing
With the Stars there's always love to be
found there or former so she could go
and be a judge and find love you know no
it's so true like so many of them are
having babies and getting married with
each other it's actually really like
cute I do want to say
um I hadn't seen a picture of the Mrs
doubtfire's son what is his name Matthew
Lawrence it's kind of anything that
doesn't have a lot of
uniqueness it's very nondescript yeah
it's a first elasti as well like both
the first name and the last name could
be first names that's not what a first C
last year is but okay uh firstly lasti
can also be when like I can't say a
person's name without saying their full
name like Jackie ashrae yeah like
Joaquin Phoenix it's both it's both
I think it's only the latter
I think it's both but I hear you and you
might be right let's move on we have to
ask Massey block
literally first elasti but
I hadn't seen a photo of this first
elasti in so long and I have to say like
he has aged quite beautifully like he
looks very yeah he looks exactly like
the kid from Mrs Doubtfire he has that
like boyish grin and like really
All-American look he's very handsome
yeah okay great chili happy for them
yeah
are you ready for our next story about
one of your favorite people
is it Mary from Sister Wives no but like
because she's spiraling she's fire leg
close close-ish guess
and I I know you're like not interested
in the Sister Wives conversation and
like you only entertain it for me and
for that I'm grateful but I'm gonna add
a layer to it that's going to make you
more interested ready
Mary is a top seller of lularoe I love
that for her girl boss yeah
um no who's someone else that you love
to talk about I don't want to say that
you love him the hacks no but like
you're close so you're saying like who
is a reality TV loser Chrisley yes yes I
heard he should be a tell-all interview
Todd Chrisley promises nothing is off
limits in his only sit-down interview
before he and Julie head to prison Todd
Chris he must be getting paid a [ __ ]
Claudia keep listening Todd Chrisley is
ready to share his truth on the latest
episode of his Chrisley confessions
podcast the Chrisley Knows Best star
revealed he will only be participating
in one interview before he reports to
prison and that his son Chase Chrisley
will be doing the honors sometime next
week even though his 26 year old son
will be tasked with conducting the
interview Todd promises that he will
still answer quote all the hard
questions feel such clickbait he also
knows his son is fully capable of
handling the task he said I'm looking
forward to that interview not because
it's going to be a softball interview uh
you have said am I allowed to ask all
the hard questions and I said you can
ask me anything I am your daddy
Daddy
Daddy okay uh moving on I'm at it I'm
mad at times for making me say that oh I
thought he was gonna do like a full like
Howard Stern 60 Minutes something like
that like something that would pay him
he owes millions of dollars in
restitution it would this is not a smart
business decision he should really put
it on patreon maybe he's selling a lot
of ads for the podcast because he will
get a lot of listens
perhaps but this is not the interview I
was hoping for like at all no I mean
like but I guess in a way he's like
building a brand for his kids like you
know what I mean yeah that's true that's
like a gift he's giving his kids he's
going away for 15 years if you watch a
show you know like he banked rolled them
entirely buying them cars and he they
lived with them so in a way perhaps this
is his way of like giving his kids
something like a business if they have a
huge podcast they can make a huge living
from that one episode
I know but like if if it's gonna be as
big as they think it's going to be like
it could sustain itself
I don't think so but maybe it's like
okay he'll do the one episode and then
maybe the kid takes over the podcast
going forward the Chrisley confessions
podcast and the Chrisley stands who
think that they've been wronged will
continue to listen
I don't think anybody thinks that
they've been wronged I just think people
think their sentencing was a little
harsh when you compare it to like you
know violent criminals who get out yeah
so they've been wronged a little bit
they also did wrong but I think they
probably still have people in their
corner you know Teresa did yeah that's
so true but like Teresa I could actually
see the argument against why Teresa
shouldn't have gone to jail like she
literally was not smart enough to know
what was going on right it wasn't the
the cases against Joe really right and
like with the Chrisley he's like there's
a paper trail of intent to steal money
from Banks you know yeah yeah
well I definitely will be watching the
interview even though like I was really
hoping I thought it would be when I saw
this headline going around I didn't open
it I just assumed it would be like a
Michael Strahan Today Show GMA thing
yeah so did I and then I kept reading
and it was even more shocking than that
yeah because like Teresa did even before
she went away uh one-on-one or after the
sentencing maybe it was two on one with
Joe a watch happen side and there were
reports she was getting paid she owed
like a million dollars of restitution to
the government like yeah at that point
you go into hustle mode Luanne I think
did her one-on-one you know everyone
does it well they're going to jail for
so long that like when they're do they
owe this restitution by you know yeah I
guess it's something like you don't
actually pay no it's just a problem for
another day maybe like maybe they come
out of jail and they start hustling but
what can they do now and and nothing
that no interview that they would get
money for is gonna put a dent in what
they owe no that's so true they stole so
much money yeah
foreign
so that's what's up with Todd Chrisley
gotta keep up with the crystals
constantly until I can't any longer are
you ready for our next story
yeah Emily Ratajkowski says men can't
handle strong women after her Pete
Davidson fling Emily radakowski is over
dating Men Who quote don't know how to
handle strong woman women oh my God I'm
one of those people who confused oh my
God who doesn't know the difference
between women and women that is one of
my biggest pet biggest what is that you
just did what is that you just did it to
me I just misspoke I didn't have a it
wasn't my brain it was my mouth
on housewives they're always misusing
women and women it's so annoying it's so
weird like it's pretty simple I agree
the high low podcast host explained in
Tuesday's episode that she hates going
out with men in particular who truly
think they want an independent partner
she said quote they're like you're
special you've done it they slowly get
emasculated and they don't know what to
do with those feelings and they resent
you and then they start to tear you down
and then you're just back to square one
she's saying this coming off the heels
of her split with Pete Davidson though I
feel like this isn't about people I feel
like if I listen to the whole episode
which no offense like not in the mood I
would think like I there's probably more
context that it's just about like her
relationships in general and probably
about her ex-husband still yeah of
course I don't think this has anything
to do with Pete because Pete has stated
you know even more powerful women and
more independent than him like there's
look at his list of of exes right and
also like they dated for a few weeks
like that's not significant enough to
like go on your podcast and slam him
no I think this has nothing to do with
him but I just can't help but like roll
my eyes like I do I know that this type
of you know man exists I'm just like
getting really tired of like this
click-baity feminism like it's so
fraudulent and it's like I saw a clip
like from her Pockets like I want to be
able to like show my tits and legislate
bills like you can you can I agree and I
fundamentally with what they're like the
movement says like I don't disagree but
the way in which it's like performative
feminism has like overtaken white women
in Hollywood as like it's the biggest
issue in the world like it's so
performative and it makes me roll my
eyes and you know what I'm about to say
controversial it makes me hate women it
does I'm sorry I hate this like female
is the future t-shirts meanwhile behind
the scenes like you never met a woman
more mean to other women in their lives
and like so judgmental of like other
women's decisions and like how they
choose to live their life lives I hate
this like it's like white women woke
feminism like I hate it yeah she's
really into it no and it's like
like the Olivia Wilde running around and
like the future is female t-shirts and
everything is female female and then
it's like you find out she was like
begging Shia LaBeouf to come back to her
movie and putting Flo another woman in a
bad position like it's all performative
it's all [ __ ] I hate this like this
movement of like women in Hollywood
talking about like feminism as if they
really even [ __ ] care like they know
and also like so judgmental of how other
women choose to lead their lives like I
don't like it to have like your one
experience then be like
generalizing like all men can't handle
strong women and it's like maybe you
just had a weak man
no for sure and this is not me
discounting that those experiences
happen and that those men exist there
are big [ __ ] losery ass men who are
so intimidated by women who make money
and who are more powerful than them like
I get it I know that it exists like but
the way in which like the message is
being communicated from this like really
polished like brand of feminism I hate
yeah
and then she goes on to say um after she
calls that Dynamic like [ __ ] up and
unfair she said that she can understand
dating women instead and having mutual
respect in a relationship she said there
might be competition but doesn't feel
like somebody's taking something away
from someone else
um she said and she referred to herself
as a bi woman earlier in the episode
well it also sounds now like your
sexuality is more of a convenience than
something you're born with and then
that's [ __ ] offensive to win who are
gay right right like I just find men
intolerable so I'm going to date women
that's not how true gay women start
dating other women it's because they
were born that way and they love women
like right then that's just offensive
and it's like
the offense continue yes sexuality is
not a convenience for you because you
couldn't find a man who handled your
power yeah
and I see that all the time on Tick Tock
when it's like uh I like need to start
dating women like women understand me
that is not what being gay is about yeah
you're born this way baby like oh she's
like I'm just not the target audience
for Emily ratajkowski's podcast like
whatsoever this like this brand of fake
ass feminism like I am a feminist to my
core and I find that I do not believe in
anything like the the feminist movement
empowers like I feel like feminism is
just like lifting up other women even if
I don't agree with them or even if they
live their lives differently than me
like I support you live your life bestie
you want to be a stay-at-home mom that's
valid you want to work and never see
your kids that's also [ __ ] valid like
I don't care that's my brand of feminism
but like this this new age Hollywood
feminism like I hate mm-hmm
but as a feminist myself I support their
right to do it you support her right to
podcasts and as a podcaster what do you
think
I just think like they're you know the
toast isn't for everyone and her podcast
is not for me yeah and I'm sure there
are people who love it and are really
inspired by it and I'm so happy for them
because that's what's great about the
internet is that you can always find
something for different people and I am
not the person to listen to this podcast
like the second you started reading my
eyes immediately like went to the back
of my head and I couldn't turn them
forward yeah I figured that this would
elicit some reaction like that
which is always fun
yeah
so you want to move on
yeah and like I would love a podcast
from edrada on the time her and her
husband decided not to pay their rent
that is more interesting to me because
that was like still the craziest like
she's had so many like not scandals but
um like press worthy moments you know
her book came out and then Pete like
she's always being talked about but I'm
still stuck on that time a few years ago
where they refused to pay rent and it
was supposed to be some sort of
political statement but they just looked
out of touch because they're literally
like multi-millionaires and there are
people who can't actually afford to pay
their rent yeah but you know what we
have to be so grateful to emrata because
she introduced us to her husband
Sebastian bear McLeod who has given us
mcclurgical material for sure I don't
know if you guys know this but that's
where the nickname mclartia comes from
because the first time I saw his name
mclared I was like mclartia
no it's true so you're right it's a
thank you for acknowledging the impact
she's actually had on us and our brand
it's it's you know there's pros and cons
to everything yeah but she has had a
major impact on our brand I would say
major major weather and that wasn't her
intended impact you know
no
but I guess you never know what what
part of your life is going to touch
people
our next story is some new couple news
new ish that I didn't see until
yesterday but we do ship here at the
toast I think is it the new couple-ish
news that we didn't see until yesterday
that's brought to you by Caraway yes it
is because I think these two are cooking
it up in the kitchen but they don't seem
like the type who wants their food to
stick to the pan
who does new year new kitchenware with
Caraway start your year off right with
non-toxic kitchenware so you can ditch
the chemicals and make healthier cooking
a piece of cake with our exclusive
discount you can now save on the full
Suite of Caraway products including
their food storage their tea kettle
their mini cookware the internet famous
cookware set is a staple for any home
and it comes in multiple colors to fit
with any design aesthetic if you watched
our Vlog recently on um patreon Jackie's
chili cook-off you could see the impact
Carraway has had on her on her cooking
skills so their non-toxic kitchenwares
are all designed for the modern home
they feature chemical free ceramic
Coatings food can be prepared with peace
of mind that know hard to pronounce
compound or chemical is going to leach
into your healthy ingredients all of
their sets come equipped with easy
access storage solutions there is no
stacking required So Gone are the days
of misplacing your Lids visit
carawayhome.com
toast10 that's toast10 to take advantage
of this limited time offer for 10 off
your next purchase the deal is exclusive
for our listeners so make sure you visit
carawayhome.com toast10 or you can just
use code toast10 at checkout it's
Caraway non-toxic cookware made Modern
again that link is carawayhome.com
toast10 or code toast10
t-o-a-s-t-10 Caraway is everything of
the sort it's really made an impact on
both Jackie and I's lives uh yeah it's
made a huge impact on my life because
it's made like cooking a little less
treacherous because doing dishes is so
much easier and I imagine for you it's
made your life easier that like Ben's
not leaving you know his tuna stuff
thousand dishes tuna stuck to the bowl
and I have a small kitchen like I don't
have a million drawers I could stack a
thousand pans in like the way they they
store is actually huge like huge impact
I love that for you some would say it's
integral much like the bees well you
know what Caraway would make a perfect
40th birthday present and so would a
lengthy tribute from your man's Justin
Long
especially when like you're so they're
so private Justin Long Penns a lengthy
tribute for Kate Bosworth's 40th
birthday he calls her my joy so I
personally missed the news last month
that they were these two had started
dating
oh I feel like they've actually been
dating for way longer I thought it was
December 2021.
2021
oh my God okay yeah no they've been
together for a while oh wow oh wow I'm
stuck I'm stuck in the past anyways yeah
Justin Long penned a lengthy message to
girlfriend and best friend Kate Bosworth
via Instagram on Monday for her 40th
birthday he said she is 40 she is also
the best part of my everyday even when
we're not together she laughs with
abandon she makes me laugh the same all
the time he went on to highlight how she
sees Beauty everywhere and in everyone
and spoke of her kindness and gratitude
she thinks everyone even When She's
suffering she's kind she's deeply
compassionate and can't hurt anyone but
she can be a rascal she loves to tease
okay I'm gonna stop reading this because
now he's going to talk about the softest
lips that she has but um to me like the
headlights I I don't think I process
this even though I'm sure someone like
will find our episode from December 2021
and be like you guys talk about this it
didn't stick that these two are dating
and that is super cute it's so cute I
feel like they're so private and they're
so real I think their relationship is
like really deep I ship so hard even
though for me like the best time
of Justin Long's life
I think was when he dated Drew Barrymore
and he did recently go on the Drew
Barrymore show to promote something and
it's clear that they are like really
good friends and have like a lot of
respect for each other and they had a
conversation about their relationship
and it was like in this really mature
healthy way and she actually was like
crying she's like I just want to let you
know like it was one of the best
relationships like you were so good to
me and I feel so good about our time
together and so it really made me like
love Justin Long even more like I knew
he was a pee jump just from like his
movies but like he's an actor so what
the [ __ ] do I know but Drew Barrymore
who I feel like is a p jow like really
putting her pee jump stamp of approval
on him after all these years it was
really it was beautiful to see it was
very mature that is really sweet and I
always think of uh Kate Bosworth and
Orlando Bloom like to me oh my god there
you know if it wasn't for Katy Perry and
the fact that like they were still
together they have a kid and like
they're so happy
um I would still be shipping so I'm glad
that like they're just running in this
like pee jump circle of like committed
relationships with uh famous people yeah
no it's true and I was pleasantly
surprised I feel like they never even
acknowledge each other publicly they're
so private this was really sweet and I
feel like it was such a
he's you know he's older he's wise like
it was a really well written very
um very sweet tribute and I feel like
that should be the bar for all of us
like if your man is writing like hbd
Katie and Justin long is doing this like
take a look inward take a look except is
it your 40th birthday right no that's
true maybe for lunch 33 hbd yeah it's
like a huge milestone that's true yeah
for the big ones
and she looks so cute in all the
pictures and it's clear they have this
like beautiful life together that we
like know nothing about and you should
go see what Zach wrote me for my 30th
oh so true oh my gosh let me go see did
he even post I definitely told him he
didn't need to because he didn't need to
but now I'm like maybe he should have
I actually like get embarrassed when Ben
does like really long lengthy captions
he definitely asked me if if he needed
to and I was like please don't
pictures of me and him like Mother's Day
anniversary birthday like the whole
thing yeah
I get like embarrassed like it's nice
but I feel like very like
I don't know it feels really private you
know yeah yeah and I'm a person who
shares everything so like I don't know
some things can be kept between so I'm
gonna walk that statement back they
don't have to pen you something like
this on Instagram but a nice card
occurred for sure and they should say
those things to you I think in one way
or another a lot of the times like in
really public relationships like people
will post like the most amazing tributes
about their partner and then like months
later they break up and you're like how
and it's because like you're saying
those things to the world to like get
validation but you don't actually ever
say them to your partner it's so true
like seven people will write like the
nicest things and I'm like wow that's
really beautiful and then they break up
and I'm like but what about
and that's why I think like people get
so invested in online relationships
because those relationships Thrive off
of that type of content like sharing
deep personal moments and deep feelings
and you find yourself doing it for the
likes and not ever actually like
investing in the relationship and like
experiencing those moments and feelings
yourself like it it's just like straight
to the gram it's it's like not it's not
a lived experience anymore it's just
content yeah
so like that happens all the time like
these couples who you're just like
there's in your mind they're perfect
because that's how they make it seem and
then literally a month later they're
broken up and you're like what well so
given this caption like they can never
break up yeah agreed no pressure but you
can never break up yeah otherwise like
it's phony baloney agree but I don't
think it is
me neither
are you ready for our fifth and final
story a little movie news a little movie
casting news
Joaquin Phoenix will be playing Napoleon
Bonaparte
plus and he is being
um you know his usual Joaquin self
Napoleon got Rewritten due to Joaquin
Phoenix's constant questioning says uh
producer Ridley Scott he said in
Napoleon not Joaquin Phoenix literally
rewriting history rewriting Napoleon
well who knows what the movie was he
said it all grew bigger and better due
to joaquin's questions and edits when
working with Joaquin Phoenix prepare
yourself for rewrites Ridley Scott
revealed to Empire magazine the casting
Joaquin as Napoleon Bonaparte for his
upcoming historical epic Napoleon
resulted in the script being entirely
Rewritten to make the actor more
comfortable Phoenix reuniting with
Ridley after Gladiator stars in Napoleon
opposite Vanessa Kirby and tahar Raheem
so Vanessa Kirby is going to be playing
Josephine I didn't know exactly who that
was but then I Googled her and she
played Princess Anne in the first season
of the crown oh no princess yeah
Princess Princess Margaret yeah yeah
yeah she was great yeah she was great so
that um made me feel positive Ridley
obviously you're gonna see this
obviously I'm gonna see this I feel like
there's not a lot of
Napoleon content out there especially
there's no like big Napoleon movie that
comes to mind
I think Joaquin is an inch I don't know
who I would cast I would probably just
assume like someone shortish but sure
yeah I I think Joaquin cool I I'm
interested I mean this Joaquin is a real
artist like he's in this for the art I
don't think there's really anything he's
put out that hasn't been critically
acclaimed he brings he brings a level of
skill and Excellence to everything he
does so I think we can expect great work
from Joaquin like I don't think yeah I'm
sure he's been like bad living in a 17th
century castle for the last year without
plumbing and without electricity trying
to get just to get into the Napoleon
do it
totally yeah what does Austin Butler do
next oh let's go to his IMDb
pre-production like the Fanfare and it's
almost it's almost like people associate
him so much with Elvis to the point
where I feel like it could potentially
be like a little detrimental to his
career it could be but you know if all
else fails he could be an Elvis
impersonator just like how Adam Lambert
became Freddie Mercury yeah um
that's actually a really good comparison
yeah I don't think that's what he wants
to do but if he hits 40 and he hasn't
booked another role like just do it it's
so true upcoming three oh he's gonna be
in Dune part two Dune was a really bad
Movie Masters of the air which is a TV
mini series
is good and the bike riders
sounds like a bunch of kids
it's in post-production uh it follows
the rise of a Midwestern motorcycle club
through the lives of it of its members
all right good he's working good I just
when when you get like such
crazy and I guess we still have Oscar
season upon us so like the Elvis Fanfare
isn't even over yet yeah Tom Hardy's in
that one Michael Shannon Jody Comer
Norman Reedus that looks like it will be
good yeah it is so awesome
so awesome
not us what just like knowing everything
about Hollywood Productions literally we
know everything about what's going on in
Hollywood okay this masters of the year
I don't know a lot of the people but it
sounds like a like a good premise it's
very I'm happy for him I'm a champion
I'm a champion of his work even though
like I am still saddened by the Vanessa
Hudgens of it all like I really am like
I personally uh stay there that's where
I am and just kind of like the word on
the street is that he's
a social climber but
you've got to be in that industry and
that you also need to conceal it better
yeah I hear that
um like there was that rumor that like
he um
he like was friends with Ashley Tisdale
like all that stuff and then he like was
in and I don't know that was just the
vibe I got that he was like jumping
around in the friend group like based on
like who was a big starter it's not that
close with Ashley anymore because like
she's probably not A-list enough for him
that's just the vibe I've gotten from
something that I saw and I mean so it's
100 true right he's dating like very
A-list I mean if you wanted to social
climb I think the Gerber family is a
great place to start Randy Cindy Kai
yeah like I mean Hollywood is a town
full of social climbers for sure so it's
just really networking and doing your
job well but you can have that be your
image
yeah so speaking of feminism I found it
really interesting like if a man is a
social climber like you're disgusting
um if a woman is a social climber I
think of it more as networking like if
she's dating like above her her class
and like using her dating to you know
get bigger jobs like I love a woman in
business I love a woman in business I
love people reaching their goals but I
think the idea of social climbing which
is more so like using people to get to
where you want to be I think it's icky
no matter the gender
yeah and when I hear someone's social
climber I picked out automatically
yes but I think people often confuse
social climbing with like networking and
just being thirsty which isn't so bad no
and I mean social climbing I guess at
its core is very similar to networking
but it's it's not because networking
it's like it's clear that this is
business and like I'm just you know
we're moving kind of Nefarious social
climbing has an air of usury to it yes
and people aren't objects that can just
be stepped on agree on your way to the
top agreed because you'll see them on
your way back down and No One's Gonna
feel bad for you
no and that's not why you do it because
they won't feel bad for you if you come
back down because you treat people with
respect agreed
and those were the past size stories I
feel as though you needed to know them
yeah no those were good ones thanks Jax
for for filling Us in yeah welcome and
Napoleon should be out in 2023 though
you can never trust those release dates
because we should have had Barbie and
Legally Blonde 2 already and wicked
Wicked
so the show is not over because it is
Wednesday and we do our advice segment
dear toasters every Wednesday and we're
gonna do that right now changing lives
help some girlies out with the help of
perfect bar if you're looking for a
protein bar that actually tastes good
well look no further than perfect bar
with their lineup of fresh from the
fridge protein bars perfect bars exactly
what you've been looking for no chalky
artificial aftertaste here they're made
with freshly ground nut butter organic
honey and over 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
that are all so good and good for you
you'll be sure to find something you
love my favorite is the dark chocolate
chip peanut butter with sea salt because
honestly whoever realized that dark
chocolate and sea salt is the Perfect
combo has my love and development Nobel
Peace Prize
they have a cookie dough texture it's
creamy and full of flavor and they're
unlike any other bars out there now they
come in a snack size which is packed
with up to six grams of proteins and 150
calories so a little goes a long way the
perfect
um bar snack sizes are Perfection like
they will keep you full they will hold
you over till your next meal they're
packed with protein they make you feel
good
they know that it'll be Love At First
Bite with perfect bar so for a limited
time they're offering you a chance to
try their refrigerated protein bars for
free here's how it works sign up for
email or text and upload a photo of your
receipt
from your local grocery store and they
will reimburse you for the cost of one
bar directly into your venmo or PayPal
account which is pretty cool all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today happy snacking
again that's perfect snacks.com
t-o-a-s-t perfect snacks.com toast all
right are you ready for deer toasters
your queen ready
dear tracks of Claude first and foremost
I absolutely love and adore you both the
bullet I would take for you too I mean
it's crazy love you girl I'll try to
keep this short my boyfriend and I have
been dating for almost three years he's
a gem however he's always had this
insanely weird and strange bond with his
mom and his sister like he will comment
beautiful and gorgeous with fire flames
and heart eyes on his sister's pictures
he'll FaceTime her often and he's a
group text with the three of them just
his mom him and his sister is it weird
that I get annoyed when reading comments
like that I feel so insignificant
because he will say the same exact
things to me I've brought it up before
and it went South am I crazy to be
[ __ ] annoyed when I see these things
please help I'm desperate for answers
and advice sincerely a confused when she
toaster okay if you asked me this a year
ago I would be totally on your team I
would say it's so weird but now as a
mama like Harry better be leaving
gorgeous comments on my Instagram fire
flames having a chat with me and any
other siblings he might have where we
just are so close like I think it's so
cute cute I think like him having a good
relationship with the women in his life
is yes ultimately a positive sign for
you and I would say like if he was
treating them like better than he
treated you that that would really
bother me but like he's treating you the
same way that he treats the women that
he loves most in his life like that he
comments on your stuff too like he's
just sharing the love with the women
that he loves sure like fire emoji on
your mom's Instagram is a little weird
from the Sun but I if Harry left a fire
Emoji my Instagram I'd be like thanks no
I get what you're saying but I think at
its core that's her problem it's like
she doesn't want to feel equal she wants
to feel special and so she's a
girlfriend if she has a wife if she was
a wife she could feel more than but
you're the girlfriend and he's not gonna
throw away the women who have cared for
him his entire life for the girlfriend
you're sounding like a kind of like a
toxic mom love it toxic boy Mom I'm a
toxic boy mom no like first of all she's
not a wife so that's true that's true
you are a wife like you're you don't
rise in the ranks yes
hopefully the question like now you guys
should be talking about like the future
and um
you know but you don't just
automatically get that placement when
like these women have nurtured him and
made him the man that he is that doesn't
happen overnight
you're so funny like you're because I
feel like before you were a mom you
would have like totally been like this
is weird I wouldn't say this is gross a
hundred percent I'd say run I don't say
like this bodes well for you in the long
run yeah no I I hear your frustrations
with like the same exact wording like
writing beautiful on your post and then
also on his sister like I understand
like get a little bit more creative like
everyone wants to feel special whether
you're a girlfriend a fiance or a wife
so I hear your frustrations I don't know
if it's enough to like make a statement
because then like you actually might
look crazy
um but I think Jackie's right like I
think if anything this is more
motivation for you guys to get to the
next level in your relationship and once
you're a wife and like the mother of his
kids like you can make demands yes you
can make demands once your wife and if
you are still feeling like you're not
being treated any better than his sister
like that's when you can say something
but what he's not gonna toss aside
no by the way I also think there's a
difference in like how he treats you and
his sister versus you and his mom like
yeah his mom should be like you know his
Queen you should respect your parents
his Queen but I I don't disagree that
like the sister all right step aside
yeah because then you start to think
about like the brothers and sisters who
are like
weirdly close who are weird period yeah
no I I agree with a lot of your
frustrations when it comes to the sister
actually now that I think about it but a
man who respects his mom even if it
might be like inconvenient to you is
signs that he was like raised well he
respects women and he respects his
parents which is literally a Biblical
um principle commandment yes also I
would say it sounds like a lot of your
concerns are like about his social media
behavior and like boys are just [ __ ]
weird on social media periods it doesn't
matter if some of this weirdness like
translated to real life or like he was
doing things in real life that were
bothering you I would be more wary but
like he has he's one celed everyone know
they're beautiful on Instagram like boys
are just [ __ ] weird on Instagram so
don't let that be the only reason why
that's true a lot of your complaints are
digital and the digital space is
irrelevant when it comes to like a man
yeah they don't know what they're doing
they don't know what things mean they
don't know messaging like so you don't
drive them to know because if they're
too plugged into Instagram culture it's
like get a life bro
I completely agree everything so the
fact that he's like a little Instagram
illiterate is actually really good it's
cute I agree I think we gave great
advice agreed
hey Jackson Claude I'm a toaster from
Sydney and firstly thank you for getting
me through the last couple of years of
becoming a new parent Mazel Tov to give
some context oh oh my God sorry I
dropped my cards not the curds okay to
give some context my in-laws are close
friends with another couple let's call
them Charles and Camilla they often um
often they babysit my two-year-old
daughter when they go visit my parents
wait sorry no
to give some context my in-laws are
close friends with another couple called
Charles and Camilla and they often and
often when they babysit my two-year-old
daughter they will go visit this couple
having them over at their house or being
in Social settings with them okay so her
in-laws will babysit her daughter and
often their friends Charles and Camilla
will come over so they know the kid
basically okay
add a meal over Christmas my in-laws
very casually mentioned that Charles has
a photo of my daughter as his phone
wallpaper screen and how sweet it is as
I thought about it more I felt like this
was a little odd and not entirely
necessary when I mentioned my concern to
my husband he said I was overthinking it
and it's just that they love kids and
that there were no bad intentions behind
it I'm not suggesting that there were
necessarily bad intention It just
strikes me as weird
so I'm Keen to get some insight and some
objective smart and talented girls what
you guys would do should I mention to my
in-laws that it makes me incredibly
uncomfortable and even ask if you could
change it or am I reading too much into
it and I just need to let it go
okay it's weird you gotta trust your gut
and yeah on the one I'm not going to try
and see your eyes whether this man is a
pedophile like because if he was he
wouldn't be like so obvious about it
with the kid on his home screen he would
be like a little more you know trying to
cover his track so maybe it's actually a
sign that things are totally fine that
he would think no that's actually but
again like I'm not a detective I'm not
trying to suss out if this man is a
pedophile but you need to trust your gut
and now what I would do and even though
this is incredibly inconvenient for you
in your life you can't say something you
can't like say I I want him to change
his background you can't even make it a
thing because the parents are going to
tell Charles and Camilla and then like
everybody's gonna have this like weird
like is yeah you thought Charles was a
pedophile Vibe you can't leave the kid
with the parents anymore sorry you need
to take the kid with you now when you're
going or find another child care I
completely agree like maternal instinct
is real even if you are overreacting
great you should only be an overreactor
like that there's nothing to worry about
it's a little [ __ ] weird and I agree
like maybe like a traditional creep
would it make it as background but I
feel like the older you get like you
don't give a [ __ ] you know yeah
I don't know I'm not trying I I can't
you know to play like psychoanalyze this
guy I would say trust your gut and and
then just don't put your kid in that
situation even if it does become
incredibly inconvenient for you perhaps
I would also suggest learning more about
Charles like does he have kids like does
he want for kids
yeah did he always want kids did he lose
a child like I feel like this is
definitely odd behavior and maybe
there's a perfectly good reason for it
yeah
find out about Charles but in the
meantime like your priority is your kid
and I don't think you're being crazy at
all did she say where she was going when
she was leaving the kid no just what she
was going they'll just babysit
babysit for a weekend or babysit for a
night just babysit That's All She Wrote
okay because maybe if it's like a night
you could have the in-laws come to your
house and maybe there's no Charles and
Camilla
around yeah but you have to like you
have to stealthily take the kid out of
that situation and you can't tell anyone
what you're doing without making a scene
I completely agree like and it's
incredibly inconvenient sorry yeah like
back out quietly in the night through
the back door no one can accuse you why
are oh you know now that he's bigger
like we're taking him you know yeah
Gaslight the hell out of him agreed
amazing advice Jackie
our third and final is the baby name
Steeler hello Jackson Claude missed
hearing you ladies after the Hiatus but
as the hard-working women in podcasting
you both deserve some R R thank you we
have a baby name Steeler on our hands
for the first two years my sister-in-law
on my husband's side and I've been in
various stages of pregnancy so we often
shared what we would name our children
even before our current children we went
through our preferred names to make sure
there was no crossover she just had her
second and after nine months of telling
everyone that she was gonna name it
Casey or Jamie she goes and names the
child rip
so I don't know if this girl is just
like cosplaying Yellowstone no okay okay
she probably is
even when I was pregnant with my son now
my husband and I were very vocal about
naming our next son if we have one rip I
even went as far as to tell my sister
while she was pregnant not to name her
son rip because that was the name we
would be using as recently as Christmas
Eve four days before she popped him out
my husband and I meant a comment to them
that we were naming our next Sun rip it
has special meaning for me and my
husband and these name Stealers didn't
even give it a second thought when they
surprised us all with the switcheroo
while they had options this was the only
name on our list
my question do I have my husband say
something to his brother or at least his
mother who also very much knew and did
not guide them away from the name
despite us not being able to do anything
about the name now I'm also all about
airing Grievances and my husband is not
he'd rather just put a mark next to
their name saying I'll remember this
this couple has no Scruples and this is
not their first offense against us they
also chose to announce this pregnancy to
the family a day after she peed on a
stick and my baby was just born and
admitted to the Nico saying something to
them won't solve anything name-wise but
should they not be alerted of their
complete lack of consideration love a
Fed Up toaster her question is to say or
not to say because at this point it's
too late
no well the lesson here is literally
stay far away from this girl she's not
to be trusted do not tell her any names
because you're putting ideas in her head
in the future like this is not a girl
you can trust so I know you probably
thought you were getting ahead of it but
if you had never even said the name Rip
in her presence it wouldn't have crossed
her mind I honestly don't know what to
tell you I Nothing's Gonna Change the
situation and like assuming that you
guys aren't Jewish like why can't you
also name your baby rip
you should say I just want to let you
know I know you know this is my name and
I know you stole it because you live
without consequences but I have not been
deterred I still will be naming my son
rip so I'm just giving you a chance you
know your baby was just born feel free
to change it yeah yeah I like that plan
a lot to be honest I don't I don't know
what to tell like I'm really stumped I
don't know how long it's been since she
had the baby like is it even an option
to change I guess like Kylie still
hasn't changed her kid's name so anyone
can do it she said the baby was born
she didn't say it was like yes as
recently as Christmas Eve which is four
days before she gave birth okay the
baby's a week old okay but they left the
hospital already so she would have to do
it like sure but I think I actually I've
never been more excited about advice
we've given but is our toaster pregnant
with a boy like what if
no she she gave birth to a son and then
told everyone that their next son was
gonna be named Rip got it but like what
if she only has girls you know right
it's hard to claim a name like
if you've got a baby without you know so
I don't I seriously I don't know what to
tell you I support any decision any
route that you choose to go I personally
am more akin to her husband like we're
gonna take a mark next to your name me
too and it's just like lesson learned
I've got a list of names and yours is in
red under a line that's how I live my
life I think that like always pushing me
to like confront people when and I'm
like no you know what not everything
needs to be a conversation but I
remember but yeah I don't remember
totally uh but no like I remember the
feeling yeah no hopefully what I would
say is I would I would remember I would
put enough distance between us and them
that by the time you have a son you can
name him rip and it's like oh I don't
know another rip we don't hang out with
them
no I actually think
um the lesson you've learned here is so
valuable because well it's it's a big
deal it's not in the grand scheme of the
world it's not the biggest deal and
things you know you could have shared
something with her even more meaningful
to you and have her betray your trust so
you just learned a valuable lesson and
if you don't internalize that lesson
like whatever happens next is on you
like you cannot trust this girl do not
trust her she is a fugly [ __ ] agreed
like stay far away from her
and also like I do think you could say
like I know you know this is my name
like don't be dumb and just letting you
know like if I'm blessed with another
son like you have not deterred me so I'm
just letting you know like we will have
two rips in the family do with that
information what you will yeah I do
think you should tell her actually like
I'm really feeling passioned
it's so hard you're in an impossible
situation also it's like yeah
she's still human I know I don't think
that you say it in like a
confrontational way I think you say like
I'm
love the name I know you know that was
my name and while you may have it like
if I have another son like no and not
coming at it in an angry place I'm just
letting like heads up like I am still
potentially using the name okay but put
yourself in the other girl's shoes for a
second like you just
gave birth a week ago and I'm and I'm a
baby's name stealer yeah
but you don't believe yourself to be
because you're like delusional because
you're like a wench you don't believe
that you're a baby named stealer because
like obvious then you wouldn't have done
it if you thought that's who you were
you know and you're like this wenchy
sister-in-law is coming for me like
seven days after I've given birth like
has she no Scruples you know that's true
yeah because then you become the villain
I think you need to let time don't come
for her in this PP era yeah it's a
protected space
yeah I agree
you're an impossible situation I don't
know what to tell you
yeah but I know what to tell you or come
up with reasons why you hate the name
let's just move on from the name no
maybe like the reason that you hate the
name is because it reminds you of this
[ __ ]
maybe that's a good enough reason yeah
like you don't even want it now it's
attached to that wench yeah I think we
should move on from the name like we
need to like you don't want to have you
and also you don't want your son if your
future son to be like a spite a groomed
baby like we just need to like break
free you have to let go
you have to okay so we're letting go
we're never trusting this [ __ ] again
like to you she's literally an
acquaintance at best
and
we're putting a mark next to her name
just like your husband said your
husband's got the answers I'm sure Matt
you have a husband with the answers no
but he's probably just doing that
because it's like his family like if it
was her family I'm sure you have no
problem we ride it Dawn yeah right like
he just wants to protect the peace
within his family which I understand too
but sometimes you have to [ __ ] stand
up for yourself but not while someone's
in the post party agreed yeah so we're
letting it go and we're never trusting
this [ __ ] again yeah Lessons Learned
that's our show you guys thank you so
much to everyone who wrote in uh we are
in need of more submissions so dear
toasters gmail.com thank you so much for
listening to the toast the Millennium
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so at Spotify iTunes sister public radio
hi everybody Guys box all the places
we've listened about guys find us the
toast leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an incredible
amazing hump day don't forget to hump
someone you love and we'll see you
tomorrow bye